we chose a random gas station in finland
and gave drivers a full tank of free gas
if they could receive a pro tableton
serve watch until the end to see how
many could do it
three tries how many liters do you think
it's gonna go 50 well that's like a 100
euros price worth competing for yes
second one
[Music]
oh still a bit too much here it was
really curved exactly
the wind is i don't know if it's on our
side or the people's side
[Music]
it's not making things easier that's for
sure
have you played table tennis before
sometimes
okay so the last serve will be with the
chocolate in honor of the five million
subscribers challenge which means
building the world's biggest chocolate
racket and actually playing with it if
we hit 5 million by the end of the year
make sure you subscribe to see this
happen
that was close
thanks
thanks for the challenge okay let's go
the truck actually stopped
for one table tennis ball
[Music]
[Applause]
are you freaking very good
[Music]
any final words it was very good effort
go string my music sante revoir so i
don't have to sell gutters for my whole
life can we hear a small sample of your
music pongfinity shout out to these
go and check it guys so this was finnish
water construction team no success this
time but good effort
our opponent gets to choose
whoever of us serves to her who looks
like they have the easiest serve
okay no offense
you hit it that's good
[Music]
got it did you see the curve did you see
the curve well done
you'll see ark was like beautiful like
the wind was coming but
[Music]
so high ticklisfa all right go for it so
the tank is almost empty so he gets full
benefit of this challenge just a new
hundred years it's big money for me for
everybody else my monday is happy day oh
that's good
thank you first person to receive the
serve he was a happy guy he said his
monday is a happy monday now that's
always nice to hear yeah that's that's
nice i see a car coming
so the next challenger
three guests yeah no next
is there a challenge here no evil get
out we need more challenges
you up for the talent yes of course
that's great i have my own table at home
oh good good try good try that was a
good try
he's coming with force last chance
that was so close it was this close it
is close all right thanks thanks there's
mental support
[Applause]
oh
calculating where the spin i'm trying
yeah
oh
[Music]
oh
good trice good prize oh they have an
electric car we will pay the electricity
and if you don't get the serve on you
have to give us red bull mostly you
should be the one serving okay lost it
we trust you we want some red bull so if
you win
we get nothing
can we have one each for sympathy or
pity or if you can
normal or zero the zero one because
that's how i feel about myself
okay but do you still wanna try like
some of our reserves
[Music]
they got it they got it
oh there is like this military guys
should we ask them today's main exercise
over
under
[Music]
oh almost
[Music]
oh pinhole
oh
good try small good try it's good
that was it that was it
nice good job good job
oh left let's go
lefties are really good at receiving
yourselves
oh yay
there was some spin on that ball
oh
and that ball is lost forever
he ran over the ball
we have tested punching the balls they
cannot handle a truck
which is surprising thank you
so to spice things up we're going to
move on to bigger tanks do you speak
english
polish yeah how big is the tank this
tank 600 liters you want to do the serve
challenge
that's good for us
so let's find our next victim from the
regular car section
she's scared she's up for the challenge
she's thrilled to join us okay are you
are you ready for the challenge oh yes
here's the racket have you played table
tennis before no yeah yes
oh she got it first try
there's no reaction
congrats that's amazing thanks i think
that's the first person ever to return
the first serve filling up milia's car
40 litres of free gas
thank you
i think you have to do the serve so we
have the battle of the beard
go easy on me
last one
thank you
[Music]
so the last one with the chocolate
racket
[Music]
46 and 101 euros
wise words you always have to try even
though you don't know how to